I'm sort of starting to hope very, very cautiously
that American farmers are
realizing that Donald Trump is the reason
that a lot of these new struggles they're
experiencing are part of their reality and
hopefully they're going to hold them accountable
for that in 2020 particularly because a lot
of those Midwest states in which these farmers
were side, we're very close in 2016 and could
make the difference between Donald Trump being
reelected or not being reelected. As you may
know, the White House has been running up
these huge deficits with their tax cut for
the rich. They've also been running up deficits
a with subsidies to farmers to make up for
the crushing consequences of Donald Trump's
tariffs, and the White House has now announced
that they're going to add an additional billion
dollars to help out farmers, but the bailout
of the farmers does not actually solve the
underlying issue, which is that the tariffs
that Donald Trump has put in place have decimated
the markets in which these farmers operate.
Soybean farmers are being destroyed in the
u s China's going to Brazil for soybeans instead
of coming here. That's great for China. It's
great for Brazilian farmers. It's terrible
for American farmers and for our own economy.
Since our farmers have less money that they
can then spend within the United States. When,
uh, the wheat farmers started to be destroyed
as a result of Trump's tariffs, China started
going to Russian regions for wheat. It's fine
for China, certainly welcomed by Russian farmers.
It's not so great for the United States. So
we're finally starting to hear from farmers
that they're recognizing that this is a direct
result of Donald Trump's trade policy, that
this is the trade war. And remember, Trump
ran on, he understands trade better than anyone.
He's going to fix trade and none of it has
happened. The question then becomes, if they
realize that the farmers that is, will they
hold Trump accountable in 2020 I have no idea,
but I hope so.
But it's important to understand that just
because you don't like Trump's trade policy
or recognize that it's been hurting you, it
doesn't necessarily mean you're going to vote
for a Democrat if you're a Midwestern republican
farmer. Now, there's also another winner from
this trade war, and this is not being discussed
that much and I think it's important. These
tariffs are a handout too. American big farming
or big agribusiness in that as the small farmers
struggle to make ends meet, they have much
less of an ability to weather unstable revenue
than do the big agribusiness companies. A
lot of those small farmers will start to think,
damn, maybe I should get out of this business.
I wonder if I could maybe sell out altogether.
Maybe some huge agribusiness conglomerate
will buy me out at a significant discount
because I'm struggling so badly, which has
the effect of further consolidating the food
production of the United States among few
very large factory farmers and multinational
agribusiness type companies.
So make no mistake if you're a farmer and
you voted for Trump, this is what you voted
for in the sense that Trump promised it. He
pretended to have a clue about tariffs and
trade. He clearly convinced enough people
that he has a clue on that to get them to
vote for him. And he did what he promised
to do. It's a disaster. And anyone who understood
what Trump was planning to do than you, it
would be a disaster all along. They did do
it to themselves, those farmers. But I still
feel for them, I guess I see them as adults
who decide things for themselves, except they
have a disease of sorts called hyper partisanship.
Like in the same way that you wouldn't get
mad at someone for being an alcoholic because
it's sort of like getting mad at someone for
being a diabetic.
Uh, we have all of us to some degree have
this partisanship that blinds us in some way,
shape or form. You become addicted to political
party. You become drunk off of disinformation
and political attack ads and talking points.
And then you end up voting for Donald Trump
and destroying your own business by virtue
of the policies that you vote in. Vote by
voting for Donald Trump in the first place.
And that's why sadly, many of these farmers
are going to vote for Donald Trump again cause
they ain't voting for no Democrat, Sissy Liberal.
They decided, I guess that a businessman with
a track record of bankruptcy, of not paying
vendors and employing undocumented immigrants
and scamming people was the guy to lead them
forward and now this is what they get, but
you know what? I still want to help them out
and I'll be doing it at least partially, partially
by working to remove Donald Trump in 2020
even if a lot of these farmers are going to
vote for their continued self-destruction
by voting to reelect Donald Trump in 2020
and many of them sadly will. Hopefully enough
of them realize not only is this Trump's fault,
but I should vote for someone else in November
of 2020 that he will lose some of those Midwestern
states that he won in 2016 way too early to
know, but obviously we will eventually figure
that out.